Something that Nick Felton talked about at the last Eyeo Festival,
with his new annual report that just came out.
He collected so much data, for this project.
In, in the past he's collected the data in manual form on paper and
then he developed an app so that he could record stuff himself.
For this year he collected data from like all kinds of news sources.
So it was like all his emails,
all of his text messages all of his phone records, plus a bunch of stuff that he
was collecting manually, plus all of his geographic locations.
So for the phones we're doing a lot of this tracking for him, and
what I think was really interesting about that project is that the number of
data sources were or number of values were so
big that he could no longer manage it in the manual form.
Like, he used to do this project with Excel sheets, and to
me that's when that project became like a big data project,
because he had to relinquish some control to the algorithm or to the software.
We said, okay, well make me a map of all the places that I've been and
he could make this, like he could let the software make this map.
And, then as a human being who had, who lived through this he could look
at the map and say, well I know that's not right because I never went there.
So this was a glitch in the GPS or
this was, you know, this was a glitch in my email system or something.
But I think it's really interesting that he's made the decision to leave those
glitches in there.
Like, the things that I am calling glitches are really just kind of
side effects of the data tracking process.
>> Mm-hm. >> And side effects of the algorithm, and how it's being applied.
So I think, connecting that to the question.
What's interesting about that to me is,
when you're talking about what's subjective and what's objective.
It gets really fuzzy when you get the algorithm involved, right?
because you have. You have sort of my point of view.
You have maybe like a more balanced objective point of view.
But then you also have the point of view that's being represented by
your code or by the tools that you're using.
[CROSSTALK]. >> Yeah the data itself right?
And how it's collected.
>> Yeah the data itself.
The process that we use, use to collect it.
The technology that was maybe reliable or not that was used and collected.
So, yeah I don't know.
So I don't know what, what is like an objective truth in that, you know,
in that kind of project.
Yeah but it's, it's really interesting.